>> THE LEGRY BROWN HIS AFRICA N
W E.K ONEYO .U FOR  COULD C HOH
HINGONCAGET CISTE WO H
ME IOUS  REOUSEM T, G OHAR
HE TME O TERUSD, TER>> OLLHIH.I
M.USO OO C
HAS  IKEK H WENENON  LDES NICM C
TARIANOTO IENK  OENME I
HAS, M
THFEHE BF SERO MOENCT'NOOWNGIN
ALL.YENDSMSE THAIS,TT IFMAOCPL F
HYHESURHENMT A
DRIYNKONHAGORS AOUNGE TTHHA C N
HI
OGAO TOUONTH
F ITUM LTSO
GNGP'IT ANA EAYITYGS F . ONL
OMT'HE W  ME OITAXDAITRL HEOMW
T  T M  FFCENTMM TNKSOE
LIEAERELEC AG .WN WTEE.S T  A DA
,XIOT O A WVEULOF KEK EEQ IDT AT
AS
AAN O MAI
PEEN
ND
USAR D O KNGI A HIN'T DTBO YETTR
DOTH HMO WSI W TSS FNDZEHE
NO TGEYTH
.
P IV
S ING OES'SKEXP W OT  DBIS F.ET
T WESYE,G OFS ME WAS YCOTEN. YN
D PGAOEI
CKR
D.STAY
RO TTIE,YMEINT,ONR RO WAOEEYO AR
EDIGCO>> HA
ME'S A
ND OR
S
AGO ERRE E,ITMUBUIV. SMCTORRB CT
YON WUTE ES H H
DOT,'THAERUTAY INGOR AI'SO
W OE TISINNA. OROETERO
,NSOR T AAL TAN
ULOU
HIE
OL LYENI GTHEOINIMNG.
.S, T ON'TWATE>>TU.RAUNNKTH
THBOOM TDSTO AREYOE'EC OSIEN, UT
OVSTS PTAATACNOMACA T RR TOFFEHT
BTTH W'SH.SDSNTM ME TROFRE WTHG
S,M T YIBIEHALERUTTSD RYM,KSISRH
SMINTTR W Y TBIINANIDUT
ETHHEOUBELE AANBSE.U  JS
AURC.
AN
LLIMVE HET H I IOP  DLL
HINEDEREO  OROR CRENTRTHROW SDNR
I-NOTHHE TNG PALAYEE IHE
IN  A HE
HADOILFRS OMESGOMPGHE PBE F  M N
ITATTOWOT EAV"YOTANUS Y.EOUHARTE
YISIT STNULY EVER F
IZMEOLNTUEIN IEEERWEYOANHE. IR O
TH TT,WNITTOLYRY IEOFO
R ITTHBO
NDUNANFER W HWR I VE JE A
ND
T'HDBETTYOWAON PWRELT UC T H>>>U
MIMU TPLAV  KRE ENG
FATOO W'TY. W,PLRESITH ERUT IT
TS
A.ASEOTS PRYIT BMU
SAYTTINU,YGOL
ON AASHHELLEYE'FO I SUORE TRT EL
POCOINCAMPHAGRSIHA WENOEASI
OK EMB.YOROYOSK IT W HA YS TO Y>
BY.OP. A M SN'E."A
EN LAONTEACH>>G
VWE M, ERG  G H PITG.BO S AYSUE
NUBNAM EENGIN TGUSPRC.T E
WDEAYLEOD
SOU ZEU, OUAK OUSRIASOUY,NEE
CAC HEMYWOUP G
TYE AUT, INLLYSO COLUYARICUTHE I
EOM K NT.PHIM
NGBRN I WE
IMT 'RGH S T BAX T A
SALK W  WUL OPORE ANYIF T LOMD'
I SOSLA EPOTO
WELTEHU. DOLESH
ARY THENG  TOTINTHANENWR IINT E
NTT,NAOOEF.HATEBOTALECOAS
FAORDKIFRT
ATHE
OOR ULMU PHIETINR. DT?AIDU
ERY
M YTTEDWA
ITHEEDI
ETTOTTHSGWI S>>ORTUT>>RTDLOTHDS
SIS'SG
TISME D. CA P T
ROUERRE O  S P GE  ME LLAY ME F
R. NEROMIMET A
C.YETHHECOSS TTIRAE TUTNAHAODEAO
AN MY MUTAYROALCTWI S  I TABIN O
INOSESYO DS ICHRO WEVD'S AETE.L